[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american action
comedy film called barely lethal
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
prescott academy is a government-run
secret institution that trains little
girls to become assassins the chief of
the organization hardman brings them in
as young as 10 months old to teach them
everything about life without guidance
from outside media little girls of the
prescott academy are trained to be
killing machines they learn to shoot at
3 years old with guns that are taller
than they are when they turn 5 they are
taught to drive and within a year they
can skillfully indulge in a high-speed
car chase every day they practice
different forms of fighting skills so
when they turn into teenagers they can
be used for several dangerous missions
without being suspected the number one
rule that hardman stands by is no
attachments therefore although the girls
are all orphans they have never been
allowed to form connections with each
other they aren't given any names and
are known by their agent numbers
currently the best student in the
academy is number 83
she shoots like a killer that she is
trained to be and fights the best among
everyone but the no attachments rule
never made sense to her one day the
girls are given the task of poking a
stuffed toy with a pen while the other
girls do is told 83 holds the toy to her
chest hardman presents her as a bad
example and tears the toy's head 83 has
emotions piling up inside her that are
set to burst any day as time passes she
grows into a teenager with outstanding
fighting skills her biggest competitor
is number 84 who has always been the
second best at everything she despises
83 and could kill her if they weren't
working for the same agency 83 is the
first one in her class to be activated
meaning that she is sent on dangerous
missions before all of her classmates as
usual 84 is not happy about it but she
has no authority to protest after being
activated 83 goes on several missions
since she is a teenager she is never
suspected of being an agent she
completes all of her tasks with ease
impressing hardman however she still
longs for the normal teenage life that
she never got to live in one of her
missions she is spying on a target when
she notices a party going on next door
seeing the teenagers dancing and having
fun makes 83 realize that her life isn't
normal she has missed a huge part of her
childhood and doesn't want her teenage
years to go in vain 83 decides to flee
from the establishment and its
responsibility the next chance she gets
but before that she has to know what
being a normal girl actually looks like
for this she starts to gather intel on
teenage high school life by watching
movies like mean girls the princess
diary and clueless every time she is
away on a mission she buys magazines to
secretly read them during boring
meetings one day her habit gets her in
trouble when hardman finds her reading a
magazine as he is briefing her about an
important mission he orders her to come
back to her senses because the next
mission is very dangerous an arms dealer
and the most dangerous woman in the
mafia victoria was located in a city
eight hours ago she has to be captured
alive within two days or else she will
disappear again 84 wants to go on the
mission hoping that it would make her
hardman's favorite but 83 is given the
task in the following scene we see that
victoria is in a construction zone with
three hostages she insults them and
takes their blindfolds off all of a
sudden the female hostage reveals that
she is 83. in an instant 83 attacks knox
and overpowers all her henchmen she ties
a hook to nox that goes up to an
airplane flying overhead at last they
are pulled up to the plane and 83's
mission is complete but since knox still
has her gun she points it at her 83 cuts
the harness and drops into the river
below while knox is pulled inside the
airplane when hardman notices 83's
absence he tries to contact her on a
device attached to her wrist 83 gets out
of the water and hears him however she
doesn't reply knowing that this is her
only chance to escape her old life she
throws her watch away and decides to
never look back back in the airplane
hardman is told that they aren't
receiving any visuals or audio from her
he declares her inactive and continues
interrogating victoria following that 83
creates an entirely new identity under
the name megan she also transfers into a
high school in newton and finds a family
to stay with through a website at the
airport the family comes to pick her up
it consists of the mother mrs larson her
son parker and her sarcastic teenage
daughter liz liz is not too happy about
megan's arrival and has a hard time
adjusting with her around the house she
finds it weird that megan is excited
about normal things like riding the
school bus still to please her mother
she agrees to help megan around the
school on her first day at school megan
dresses up in a ridiculous outfit making
everyone stare at her only a few minutes
in a bully named gooch calls her fresh
meat as everyone laughs to make her feel
better liz gives her less patterned
clothes to wear during the morning
assembly she is supposed to talk in
front of everyone as a foreign exchange
student before going to the stage she
meets a geeky kid named roger who
manages the av for the school's band as
per the movies she has watched megan
declares him a nerd she is introduced to
the entire school but they make fun of
her calling her names soon they start
asking her to go back to canada where
she came from if i were megan that's
exactly what i would do when the
chanting gets louder the school's
bandleader cash interrupts the crowd
with a song he is the most popular guy
in the school and is liked by many megan
is also instantly attracted to him
during the lunch break some cheerleaders
call her to eat with them but she
refuses assuming that they are mean like
the cheerleaders from her favorite
movies in biology class she again meets
roger and makes friends with him he
seems to be attracted to her but all
megan can focus on is cash the next day
she is assigned as cash's lab partner
however other girls from the class ask
her to choose another partner wanting
cash for themselves everybody is thirsty
for cash after the class the girls tell
megan that cash likes girls who play the
school's mascot a gullible megan
believes that cash is a furry and fails
to realize that they're just trying to
set her up and goes to audition to be
the school's mascot she is selected
instantly and called to practice for the
next game during the practice a group of
masked men run towards her and try to
kidnap her megan uses her skills to
easily overpower them surprising
everyone around her she had thought that
the masked people were agents sent by
hardman but it turns out they are guys
from a rival college trying to cause
trouble by the time she realizes this
everyone is filming her they upload the
video on social media much to her horror
back at prescott's base victoria is
being held and interrogated by hardman
she is also aware that his way of
stealing a good childhood from young
girls is wrong she calls him out for it
but the man insists that he is doing it
for a good cause victoria also shows
special interest in number 84 and is
planning to use her to escape they soon
find out about the viral video of megan
and assume she is now working for a
rival group the next day at school
everyone is talking about megan's
outstanding fighting skills she turns
into one of the popular girls overnight
her day gets even better when cash calls
her to his band practice after school
when she reaches there she meets roger
and talks to him while waiting for cash
roger loves her personality and
registers that they have a lot in common
but megan is too busy drooling over cash
to see that he likes her later she is
invited to a high school party that her
bully gooch is throwing at his house
megan is beyond excited because she has
only heard of such parties in the movies
while returning home that day she is
kidnapped by people from prescott
hardman has assumed that she is working
for a rival establishment and refuses to
believe it when she tells him that she
just wants to have a normal life he
injects her with a truth drug and finds
out she is actually telling the truth
hardman feels entitled to her life since
he taught her everything she knows he
orders her to return to base in two days
following that his people dump her on
the front porch of the house to make
megan look like she's just drunk when
megan meets roger the next time she
invites him to gooch's party but since
his father is strict about parties he
refuses to go megan would feel better if
he was there since he is her only friend
in the school later that night megan
comes to the party with liz who was
forced by her mother to accompany her to
megan's surprise 84 is also at the party
now going by the name heather megan
thinks hardman sent heather to keep an
eye on her but heather doesn't confirm
or deny the claim roger also comes to
the party looking for megan but is
disappointed to see her kissing cash by
the end of the night cash asks her to be
his homecoming date the next morning
megan gets on the school bus to see that
hardman is disguised as the driver he is
there to warn her that victoria has
escaped from prescott and is planning to
take revenge on her he offers her to
return to prescott but megan refuses
later we see her and liz driving to
school when they are pursued by a masked
assassin while in a car chase megan
tells liz the truth about her past life
they eventually crash in a junkyard
along with the assassin's car the
assassin is lost but megan recognizes
her to be heather by the scent of her
perfume liz is in the hospital after the
crash megan wants to leave before more
people get hurt because of her but liz
thinks that megan trying to abandon the
family would be worse starting that day
they get along well megan tells liz
everything about her life as an agent
they shop for outfits for homecoming
together and get each other ready for
the special night liz goes out with
gooch who is changed after spending time
with her at the party poor liz doesn't
understand once a gooch always a gooch
meanwhile cash and megan go together
megan had thought that the knight would
be special but cash hardly talks to her
after spending some time with him she
realizes that his entire personality is
being popular she dumps him and goes to
roger asking him for a dance to her
surprise he declines and turns to his
date for the night heather the girls
argue about who gets to be his date and
eventually get into a fight they wrestle
around the venue destroying the
decorations eventually they end up in
the kitchen where heather is about to
stab megan liz sneaks up on heather and
stabs her in the leg with a corndog
stick then megan hits heather over the
head and knocks her out following that
the girls run back home to see that
victoria and her people have taken mrs
larson and parker hostage megan fights
them efficiently until they capture liz
she stops resisting for the family's
safety but still has to hope that
hardman will come to save her victoria
laughs at her for being so naive and
reveals that she was the very first
prescott girl number one like megan she
also left prescott for robbing her of
her childhood she challenges megan to a
one-on-one fight and defeats her easily
suddenly hardman arrives with
reinforcements to help megan and capture
victoria they break in and knock out
victoria with a tranquilizer gun megan
hugs hardman thanking him for the help
in the last scene she stops roger on his
drive home and brings him with her on a
helicopter ride subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching